he dibujado varias versiones de la misma
superficie es decir de hecho sólo hice
una superficie y la copié cinco veces
hice cinco copias de ella y lo que
quiero es que pensemos por un momento en
el valor de una integral la integral de
línea de cada uno de los campos
vectoriales es decir estoy pensando en
la integral de nuestro campo vectorial
efe punto punto de r sobre la curva sé
donde déjenme explicarles quién es cada
cosa que en este caso es la curva que
define a nuestra superficie es decir la
curva en su frontera la curva es la
frontera que define la región en el
espacio de tres dimensiones de esta
superficie de cada una de estas
superficies y f es un campo vectorial o
una función vectorial
que está definida de forma distinta en
cada uno de los casos ok entonces a
partir de esto quiero yo ver o pensar en
el valor de la integral de línea de cada
uno de los casos cuando estamos
cambiando el ejemplo del campo vectorial
ok entonces vamos a iniciar en este
primer caso este que está acá arriba y
algo que hay que notar es que la curva
que define esta superficie no es lo
mismo recorrerla en el sentido de las
manecillas del reloj que es hacia acá el
sentido contrario entonces yo voy a
recorrerlo en sentido contrario a las
manecillas del reloj y vamos a ir viendo
qué pasa con este con este valor de la
integral entonces por ejemplo si
empezamos aquí si vamos recorriendo la
la superficie en esta dirección
entonces notamos que nuestro recorrido
sobre la trayectoria va en la misma
dirección que el campo vectorial
entonces en ese sentido esta integral en
esta parte es positiva vamos a ver qué
pasa si seguimos por aquí si vamos
subiendo en ésta en este sentido digamos
podemos pensar como que el campo
vectorial que es constante
es digamos ortogonal o qué es
apendicular a nuestro recorrido entonces
vamos a pensar que aquí en realidad
estoy agregando nada es decir estoy
agregando 0 a este a este valor de la
integral sobre sobre esta curva que pasa
cuando nos saltamos a esta región de la
de la curva que define a la superficie
es decir si ahora recorremos en esta
dirección
y déjenme poner bien las flechas y
recorremos ahora en esta dirección
estamos recorriendo en el sentido
contrario en el que apunta el campo
vectorial entonces en este caso el valor
de la integral es negativo sobre este
pedacito y bueno cuando bajamos cuando
bajamos
que estamos recorriendo esta bajada
sobre la superficie aquí otra vez
podríamos pensar que son ortogonales el
recorrido de la trayectoria con digamos
la dirección en la que apunta el campo
vectorial entonces vamos a poner que es
0 que es lo que podemos notar si este
campo vectorial es constante digamos
estas longitudes son iguales entonces
podríamos pensar que este valor negativo
que está acá arriba es igual a este
valor pero que acá abajo es positivo
pero como son signos distintos en
realidad se cancelan digamos esto es
porque el campo vectorial es constante
tenemos algunas propiedades de que sea
la misma longitud en fin vamos a pensar
que en efecto estas dos magnitudes se
están cancelando ok entonces en este
caso
en este caso tenemos que la integral del
campo vectorial
punto de erre sobre la curva se es 0 ok
en este caso se anulan ok está perfecto
vámonos al siguiente caso a ver qué pasa
con este si vamos recorriendo a lo largo
de esta de este pedazo entonces tenemos
que aquí otra vez coincide la dirección
entonces tengo que el signo es positivo
que pasa a la hora de ir subiendo cuando
vamos subiendo otra vez podríamos pensar
que es ortogonal verdad es decir este
punto hacia arriba y esto es bueno este
apunta la dirección de la trayectoria de
forma verde
vertical mientras que el campo vectorial
ya sea aquí arriba o abajo apunta de
forma horizontal entonces vamos a pensar
que es 0 otra vez en este caso qué pasa
cuando nos recorremos digamos esta
sección entonces ahora a diferencia del
caso anterior
tenemos que coincide el campo vectorial
con la dirección en la que recorremos la
trayectoria entonces aquí le asignamos
un valor
y eso parece más bien como una
estrellita
un valor positivo muy bien y ahora
finalmente cuando bajamos pues tenemos
el mismo caso de que lo hacemos digamos
de forma vertical y el campo vectorial
apunta de forma horizontal así que
tenemos cero cuál es la gran diferencia
con el caso anterior aquí hubo un cambio
en la dirección del campo vectorial
verdad hubo un cambio en la dirección en
esta parte de abajo apunta hacia la
derecha y arriba apunta del lado
izquierdo entonces en realidad podríamos
pensar aquí bueno de hecho podríamos
garantizar que la integral es positiva
ok
este valor es positiva el de la integral
sobre la curva cerrada ahora esto a qué
se debe pensemos lo por ejemplo en este
en esta sección es en donde hubo un
cambio en la dirección y podríamos
pensar que tenemos por ejemplo un palito
aquí tenemos un palito que está no sé
digamos que este campo vectorial
representa el campo de velocidades de un
fluido por ejemplo aquí hay un fluido
que se está moviendo y las flechas nos
apuntan qué tan rápido y en qué
dirección lo está haciendo entonces si
ponemos un palito aquí lo que va a hacer
este palito por digamos por acción del
fluido del agua digamos es empezar a
girar ok entonces este campo vectorial
lo que tiene es un rotacional tiene un
rotacional
en rotacional ok y de hecho este
rotacional es positivo sale
este
piensa que estar escribiendo tengo un
rotacional
positivo
muy bien entonces cuál fue la gran
diferencia en este caso tengo un
rotacional es decir hay un cambio en la
dirección que hace que a lo mejor un
palito si está en un líquido pues
empiece a girar no ok vámonos a nuestro
tercer caso aquí por ejemplo si vamos
recorriendo en esta dirección
coinciden entonces otra vez le toca ser
positivo pero el campo vectorial está
diseñado para que cuando estemos
subiendo coincida nuevamente con él con
la dirección en la que recorremos la
trayectoria y eso pasa también acá
arriba ok y también ocurre cuando vamos
bajando
entonces en todos lados está ocurriendo
el que coincide la dirección de la
trayectoria en la que la recorremos con
la dirección del campo vectorial ok
entonces en este caso la integral de el
campo vectorial a lo largo de nuestra
curva es más positiva ok es más positiva
aquí se deberá esto bueno en este caso
podríamos ver que también tenemos
cambios en la dirección y tenemos
rotacionales podríamos pensar en el
mismo ejemplo del palito que está
girando pero aquí el campo vectorial de
ayuda muchísimo entonces en este caso
también podríamos decir que tenemos más
rotación al que el caso anterior más
rotacional será no sé quizás ya te está
dando alguna idea que mientras más
rotacional más positivo es esta es esta
integral ok
y en realidad efe lo que quiero notar
ahorita es que efe la función en el
campo vectorial puede hacer cosas muy
locas afuera de esta superficie no no sé
exactamente qué es lo que está haciendo
pero dentro tiene esta configuración
sólo nos interesa ver qué es lo que pasa
dentro de la superficie vámonos con este
cuarto caso
por ejemplo entonces en este cuarto caso
lo que vamos a tener es que si
recorremos en esta misma dirección
ok coincide completamente entonces
tenemos que es positivo a like al a al
ir subiendo ok
otra vez digamos son ortogonales y tengo
cero ahora cuando recorro esta parte
hasta aquí tengo un valor positivo pero
aquí ya hubo otra vez un cambio en la
dirección entonces cuando recorro esta
última parte digamos aquí voy a tener un
pequeño valor negativo que pasa cuando
voy bajando otra vez pues eso pues será
nulo ok son ortogonales vamos a pensar
que son es cero y por lo tanto que es lo
que me queda este campo vectorial
digamos tiene un valor si es positivo es
muy pequeña en la parte en donde es
negativo pero no es tan positivo como
este segundo caso es decir si comparamos
con estos dos este tenía un campo con un
valor de cero so integral a lo largo de
esa curva y éste tenía un valor positivo
pero muy positivo este tiene una
partecita negativa y que le resta le
resta valor ok entonces en ese sentido
podríamos hacer esta comparación donde
está la el rotacional en estos cambios
por ejemplo si aquí tenemos un palito
otra vez tenemos un palito aquí que este
es el campo de velocidad de un fluido
entonces este palito va a girar en esta
sección vámonos al último caso que nos
dice el último caso bueno aquí por
ejemplo podríamos ir recorriendo la
la trayectoria y tenemos un valor
positivo lo que hay que notar en este en
este mismo ejemplo es que también
tenemos cambio de direcciones por
ejemplo tenemos este cambio de
direcciones y este otro cambio de
direcciones ok entonces estos
representan dos rotacional es por
ejemplo distintos es decir si yo pongo
un palito aquí que está flotando sobre
este fluido entonces éste gira de esta
forma pero si yo pongo un palito de este
lado gira en sentido contrario entonces
quiere decir que esté roto estos 2
rotacionales se anulan es decir tienen
direcciones contrarias ok entonces
entonces podríamos pensar que sí que si
tenemos estos dos rotacionales de forma
distinta pues entonces la integral sobre
esta superficie va a ser cero y vamos a
ver que si miren vamos a terminar este
recorrido por ejemplo qué pasa si
subimos ahora por aquí entonces otra vez
tengo que en esta sección es cero y
ahora cuando recorremos esta parte
notamos que este campo vectorial apunta
en dirección contraria donde me estoy
moviendo entonces tengo un valor
negativo ok entonces realmente si hubo
varios cambios de dirección pero al
final el que me importó fue el que está
hasta arriba y luego cuando vamos
bajando cuando vamos bajando aquí tengo
valor cero entonces otra vez qué fue lo
que pasó tuvimos que la integral la
integral de f
sobre esta trayectoria sobre esta curva
sobre esta trayectoria fue otra vez cero
pero a diferencia de la primera aquí no
teníamos un campo vectorial constante
sino si teníamos varios cambios de
varios cambios de dirección entonces qué
que qué fue lo que ocurrió aquí entonces
déjenme déjenme ir bajando e ir anotando
algunas cosas
será que todos estos ejemplos todos
estos ejemplos me están dando idea de
que el rotacional tiene mucho que ver
con el cálculo de la integral de línea
será cierto por ejemplo esto esto nos
sugiere que como que hay que sumar todos
los los rotacionales es decir si yo
quiero calcular la integral de línea de
f
a lo largo de esta curva es decir de r a
lo largo de esta curva será cierto que
esto va a ser igual a la suma a la suma
de todos los rotacionales y eso se
representa como una integral verdad si
yo quiero sumar muchas cosas a lo largo
de esto pues será la suma del rotacional
de f ok y esto lo vamos a hacer a lo
largo de toda la superficie es decir
vamos a sumar todo el rotacional ok
ahora respecto a quién tengo que
integrar bueno pues aquí es en una
integral es una integral perdón sobre
una superficie entonces tengo que hacer
producto punto con n ok
y todo esto multiplicarlo por d s de qué
otra forma puedo escribir esto como
vimos en algunos vídeos anteriores esto
es lo mismo que la integral sobre la
superficie s del campo vectorial
efe
pero voy a hacer producto con de ese
donde se vamos a pensarlo como un vector
sale entonces qué es lo que estamos
haciendo esta es una intuición de que la
suma de los rotacional es sobre la
superficie tiene mucho que ver con la
integral
a lo largo de la curva que define a esta
a esta superficie y todo esto el
objetivo de este vídeo de este vídeo
perdón era dar idea de qué era lo que
estaba pasando y si en realidad esto
aunque ahorita lo planteamos como una
pregunta en realidad es cierta y tiene
un nombre ok
tenemos tenemos un nombre para esta idea
y lo expresamos con el nombre del
teorema de stocks
el teorema de stocks
ok este teorema stoxx es lo que
justifica que podamos hacer estas
igualdades pero vamos a explorarlo un
poco más en futuros vídeos